episode 10 that's right one zero you
have made it so far down your Ikea
Journey that today we're talking about
the Nitty Gritty we are talking about
sections and sectional details
all right let's Dive Right In to our
section and our sexual details first of
all what we want to do is jump back to
our ground floor plan and see what's
happening we can undo our Trace
reference so we don't have to see the
extra bits and pieces if you zoom out a
little bit you'll see just like our
elevations we have our sections on the
left hand side pick any of your sections
let's grab section one command D and
move it across where you cut your
section completely up to you and it's
all about construction details and
construction information for me what's
going to be really important in this
section will be potentially right here
by cutting through our window our
laundry bench our laundry our bathroom
our bedroom and again another window
we're gonna see a variety of different
elements in the construction
so what we want to do is either go to
our section panel on the right hand side
to activate that section or right click
on that section and view this section
personally I'm just going to double tap
section one on the right hand side now
just like elevations you could change
all of your settings for your sections
personally sections are about
construction and construction
information I do not like having them
colored I also like to have a uniform
cut pen fills have to say it slowly on
black as well so let's do that press OK
jump back to section you see everywhere
we've cut through is shown as black if
you've somehow stumbled upon episode 10
of this amazing journey my name is David
Thomas I'm a registered architect here
in Western Australia and this is the
completely free archicad course if you
need help anywhere along this journey
make sure you jump onto the Discord chat
down below it's completely free
otherwise go back to episode one start
from the beginning and find your way
back to right here right now which is
episode 10. first of all when we're
documenting sections like I mentioned
it's all about structural information so
what do we want to represent what do we
want to showcase and how do we want to
detail it let's smash through this
relatively quickly to give you guys as
much information as humanly possible
first of all you want to make sure that
you're showing your boundary line and
your natural ground level so if I draw a
straight line somewhere roughly here
turn that Arrowhead off like then know
that my boundary line is sitting below
my slab depending on what kind of slab
you have it's most likely going to be
sitting a little bit above that slab as
well so let's go 50 minus so this is
that down from the slab to the ground is
50 mil you can detail all this in 3D
obviously or you can do it in 2D for the
purpose of this we're just going to grab
some 2D fill we're going to go across to
our drafting fill change this to
lightweight concrete change our settings
to black and white this is going to give
us a white background and black all
about hatching what we then want to do
is start drawing out actual slab so
where it's cut across we have a slab all
the way across I want my slab to be 100
millimeters thick coming back finishing
that slab off here in Australia slabs
typically have Edge thickenings as well
slab thickening would look something
like this and it would be a two by one
ratio so you'd have a slab thickening
something similar to what I've shown
there that then would be duplicated on
the other side so we can mirror it copy
it drag it to where it needs to be use
our magic wand tool to extend that hatch
and delete what is not necessary
generally speaking we also have strip
footings in Australia depending on what
your soil conditions are so let's do 500
by 300 as a strip footing and we'll also
replicate on other side we need to
Showcase that all of this below the
ground is Earth first of all let's
simply just draw a hatch let's bring it
to the back of the image and let's
change this to Earth I like my Earth
feel to be a lot lighter so you don't
actually see it you don't know what's
going on and I also disregard the solid
line I do want my Earth feel to be in
front of the structure but I then want
my actual slab to be in the front so I'm
going to go through select them all
bring it back to the front now we have
one section to talking about how the
building connects to the ground which is
critically important we would then most
likely have a vapor barrier so as an
example we'll just grab a dashed line or
a hidden line let's go small dashed
we'll use the blue and what we'll have
is a vapor barrier now the easiest way
is to Simply trace your slant select one
of the edges and offset that by about 50
mil bring it to the front so it's
clearly visible you have a vape barrier
here depending on where you're building
who you're building with how you're
constructing that Vapor Barrier may also
wrap around the actual strip footing so
if you extend that 20 mil around the
strip footing you will then see a clear
indication of a vapor barrier around a
strip footing now all of these are
subject to Structural Engineering your
site etc etc there's so many details
that we aren't talking about in this
section right here right now generally
speaking there is a vape barrier there
is probably some sort of insulation
there might be individual thickenings
throughout the slab to toughen up the
slab depending again on the soil
classification I've just noticed some
Shadows aren't in my section so jump
back to ground floor plan open up my
settings go to shadows and turn that off
you don't want Shadows on each section
it is really cool structural information
it is not anything for presentation
purposes only it needs to tell the
structural story now let's imagine this
was going to be a timber frame house
what would that entitle and what would
we see well first of all we'd most
likely see a very simple Timber plate so
if we just get pure white box with an
outline and we draw a Timber plate at
the bottom it would be
a 90 by 45 mil plate and we'd have a 10
mil offset for that plasterboard and
then of course to indicate a Timber
plate here we would have a simple x
pattern if this was a steel plate it
would be a c channel or a zed purlin or
whatever it was that you were utilizing
and then we would also show where the
rest of our plates go if you want to get
really technical you might show a double
play at the bottom you'll show a plate
underneath your windowsill your shoulder
plate at the top of your windows head
and again at the top of your actual wall
now next what you'd show is most likely
insulation in that wall so if we find
insulation we can use bat insulation
change that to gray as well or change
that to Black now typically speaking
sections are not at a 1 to 100 scale
they are generally at 1 to 50 or larger
so make sure you increase your sections
and that way you can continue to move
forward now this isn't a Timber framing
code or whatever framing video at all
but you'd most likely have some sort of
header beam nothing
over the top of your window to carry the
load support through the sides whatever
was required under your framing code
requirements same as the seal plate you
might Beef It Up do whatever you need to
do generally speaking that's what our
wall would look like and that's what we
would be showcasing for the rest of
these I'll quickly go ahead and update
all of these live floor walls so you can
see what I'm talking about now to make
sure I don't get a bunch of hate
comments on this video as well you can
speed up this process by coming in to
your section details changing from
uniform to cut fill and making sure a
uniform pen is selected by doing so and
coming back into our section you'll see
that the insulation is actually shown on
these wolves so if I was to delete this
ugly 2D hatch that I've created you'll
see the beautiful installation actually
shown whereas in the middle walls or the
internal walls you delete it and it's
empty because there is typically no
insulation besides acoustic insulation
in these walls
whereas external walls are specifically
earthwool or something of those sorts
continuing to move up the ranks what you
will see is a Timber floor now this
floor is 300 mil wide and it is a
composite so it does have a few layers
to it very similar to what we've done
for our walls is what would happen for
this Central floor so first of all we
would have some form of ring vein 270 by
65 Timber stud on the outside now
depending on which way your floor joists
were going you could have these at 450
centers 600 centers whatever your
engineer called for it personally I love
450 centers for a Timber floor it makes
it quite solid and doesn't feel bouncy
whatsoever so it is much nicer to finish
off a Timber floor with 450 Setters and
then the odd one out is just joined to
put insulation in the easiest way is
open up the object use the insulation
drop it in rotate it and adjust it to
the right size that you need now to make
your insulation fall to the back and
your beans
actually stand through you would
obviously just make that insulation a
lighter color and push it to the back
now we have some sort of Timber
floorboard here we have nothing wrapping
underneath so we would have to Showcase
that via our clean fill
so what we could do is introduce a 10
millimeter fill and bring that to the
front as pure black and then we could
also extend that edge another 10
millimeters forward there to showcase
the edge of our Timber floor was wrapped
around it was concealed with whatever
cladding we had and we would simply move
the wall above it to align 10 mil and
then we could extend our cladding all
the way out and by showcasing that right
there you would indicate that this
cladding goes down past your slab Edge
and then you'd have a different material
returning to the end obviously even at
once 50 that is quite hard to seed it is
nearly impossible to see so what you'd
have to do is a sexual detail
that can be easily achieved by using
your detail tool here on the left hand
side if you select the detail tool start
drawing a basic Square
try align it to only the information you
want to showcase because it will make a
2d carbon copy of this area for me I
like that shape there I'm going to click
over here and it's going to tell me that
this ID is on this layer now once you
create details you'll find them appear
in the details section so if you double
click the detail you'll see that detail
be blown up to 1 to 25 or 1 to 10 or
whatever you decide to make it then
utilizing this much larger detail will
print obviously much larger you can go
through and detail this with impeccable
accuracy you can showcase exactly the
size of your studs you can showcase your
skirtings your plasterboard how it
aligns how the floorboard comes in
underneath that skirting where that
particle board stops how this ring beam
is bolted to the side what kind of
cleats you're using much much much more
throughout a residential project you may
have 20 to 50 to 100 of these details
depending on how much information and
how much in architectural input you wish
to place on the project the upper walls
would be identical to lower floor walls
and you would go ahead and duplicate the
same kind of system obviously the walls
would stop at the underside of the beam
or depending on how your Carpenter wish
to brace them it could actually extend a
little bit further and then be braced in
between the actual Rafters but for the
purpose of the that is one long rafter
with some tin on top and then again
we'll Place some insulation align it to
our Rafters for basing and sizing and
away we go we have our section well
detailed well-informed and as we
progress we add more and more and more
the last thing you may want to consider
in this section is actually how we
protect the top of the roof so let's
grab one of these Timber studs drag it
to the top of this parapet here in the
timber wall what would happen in this
scenario is basically the corrugated tin
that is sitting on top right here would
have a flashing that flashing would be
cut into the corrugated tin it would
then reverse back two three four five
hundred mil depending on the weather in
the regions but they pushed all the way
up that wall returned pressed over our
actual top of wall returned down back
and then it would either
flick a little tiny bit with a silicon
bead or wrap around and interlock into
the cladding system itself
either way you're flashing up the top
I'll just change the color for clarity
would protect the top of the wall from
any weather and any water in a section
typically you wouldn't showcase any of
the fixed Furniture so if I was to go in
turn my fixed Furniture off we would
hide all of that you can show your
plumbing fixtures if you want just
simply change those to a different color
so they aren't pink and drive me crazy
to take this one step further and really
think about our construction and our
detailing these wet areas as well as
this wet area at the top would most
likely be tiled which means they would
most likely be set down to allow for the
screed
and the tiling to actually be utilized
in these rooms now what do I mean by
that well first of all what we would do
is let's just align these hot spots if
we set this slab down 30 millimeters we
would then also set this section of the
slab down 30 millimeters and allow a two
to one change in the grade between the
bottom of the slab what you'd see then
is approximately 20 millimeters of
screed so let's make that yellow for
clarity which will allow you to
manipulate the uneven levels of the
concrete and provide a perfectly level
surface for your tiles to go on and then
last but not least you would have 10
millimeters of tiles which I'll make
black for the purposes of argument on
top of that screen
now this wall here you would either make
sure that the concrete is stepped up
with a little bunding plate in between
the walls so that your screed creates a
natural barrier between and you only
have to waterproof up the walls Not
underneath or you could run it
underneath and do a completely different
waterproofing detail nonetheless that is
the core and most important elements of
a structural section you really need to
focus on the details the elements Zoom
right in to every little bit think about
every little connection Point how it's
going to work what's going to happen I'm
going to showcase the bolt coming
through this bottom plate doing it is
show the insulation on the side which
then results in our footings having to
move to the right hand side and being
dropped do we need to show all the Rio
do we need to show the chairs do we need
to show any hydronic in slab eating are
we going to show a drop ceiling in our
bathroom potentially we want to take
some of these potentially we want to
take some of these Timber studs drop
them 300 millimeters and create a false
ceiling for ourselves because we might
find that we need this extra space for
mechanical ventilation for additional
lighting for heating for all sorts of
things so this is where we detail how
our ceiling Heights are where they go
and what they need to be anyway that's
all from me team thank you so much for
watching I hope you enjoyed the video if
you did Smash the Subscribe button down
below the full arcad course is to the
playlist the side of me and like always
I'll see you next Monday